let's go camping
me and Jacob here we're getting on a
plane for five and a half hours to fly
to Oregon to do a survival school you're
ready to learn how to survive in the
woods
[Music]
[Music]
worries oh
[Music]
yeah
we're here with Joel vanderloon and he
runs a survival School here in Sisters
Oregon me and Jake are gonna learn to
survive and you know what if we don't
die then we know we were a success right
I watched a couple of videos seems like
you got some skills already oh well you
know good editing big city would look
good all right we'll have the card we'll
follow you perfect we'll see you there
oh this is a pretty spot oh look at this
we got a little dog yeah this is Harley
hi Harley
have you seen these z-pack tents no
that's a two-man tent no way yeah yeah
is that crazy light that is unreal
that's like I mean that's the most
lightest that's the lightest hand of it
it's waterproof is this what you're
setting up yeah I can't wait to see it
that's the big one of the biggest
complaints
all right oh look at that that's
gorgeous
there's a good chance we'll end up
sleeping in a shelter we build ourselves
but just in case I like to have the tent
that way Jacob always has a place to get
it take a nap if he gets tired it's hot
out here Jake we gotta make sure you
drink enough water Maybe yeah make some
water bud well I got a camp set up and
Jacob taken care of first order of
business we're gonna learn a little bit
about animal traps we're gonna try to
catch some dinner so I think we should
make up a Paiute Deadpool trap okay but
ideally a flat surface so that we can uh
we can we can pancake the the animal the
longer and The Wider the better so they
have less chance of escaping five times
the body weight is what we're shooting
for yeah
oh is that the squirrel squisher 2000
and that's like a deal you see how flat
that is yeah yeah we're looking for
three rocks we're gonna make three traps
well that looks pretty decent beautiful
that's a good one
the post piece generally I kind of go
with the palm palm of the hand lens
the the hinging piece we're going to go
about double double the length of that
the post piece yeah just get out of one
stick you can increase the chances so a
nice little like Phillips head
screwdriver yeah I'm just gonna cut in a
little v-notch this guy fits in here
I'm gonna wrap that around the back
right here and then we'll get this nice
and tight and we'll measure how much we
need there's a nice little toggle piece
it's kind of like the thickness of a
pencil really
pushing the hinge piece down until I
wrap this toggle around and then once
they've got the toggle around I can
transfer
I should be able to transfer weight into
the toggle alone and now I'm going to
take a little bit of a measurement where
I want this to be cut off
this is how easier bite it off this is
how you do all of this with just like
one-handed and it should hold up oh that
is I can see what you mean that is just
yeah like a hair delicate yeah where we
go and set up our traps we're going to
sit on top of a log we want hard hard
surface and hard surface to kill them so
you're saying you want to put them
between a rock and a hard place a rock
and a hard place all right got it I'll
start pouring at the bait and when they
do squish squish and then we have a
squirrel pancake Jake yeah I'm not I'm
not much of a hunter but you know I know
with fishing it's like 10 equipment 90
location you know 100 and hunting is the
same thing I mean you can make the best
trap in the world but if you're not
sitting where there's a lot of animals
yeah it's not going to do any good yeah
so
that's the yeah that's the right hand
right
but it's light and then also you know
you can use it as baits peanut butter is
a classic squirrel bait and here in
Oregon the squirrels prefer the organic
non-GMO locally sourced peanut butter so
it has to be
look at this I think that's an old
ground squirrel then you see it's got
all this junk in there so maybe it
wasn't used too recently they like to
dig the Burrows under those big rocks
then a bear or a fox can't dig them up
easy
there's another old burrow right there
we got a sighting
you've seen a squirrel we're in the
right place he is right there up in the
tree the little Pine squirrel right
there we'll have one here and then we'll
move down that way we'll sit a couple
down there he
[Music]
got so many difference all right we got
some peanut butter right in there we're
gonna see if we can't catch a little bit
flat squirrel
oh yeah I can see this is where a
squirrel comes up here and perches and
they'll sit there and eat the pine cones
and get the seeds out of them
so
it might be too slick and then
all right I think I think we got it it's
a trap that folks is how you set a
Paiute Deadfall trap in Under 12 hours
set my camera by the Trap and we're
gonna see if we can't film it
and then the board was just like and I
went hey okay oh there we go oh Jacob
did you pick your nose did you pick your
nose oh oh don't eat your booger without
eating your bugger oh oh wait that was
peanut butter we're good oh
phew Hey Jake are you hungry yeah okay
I'll get you some lunch you want some
papoosas sure well I'm getting lunch
ready Joel set Jacob up with a little
bow and arrow here the other side there
we go aim
all right guys the food I'm making is
pupusas it's a food that's traditional
down in El Salvador and parts of Central
America they're absolutely delicious
super easy and something you can do on
campouts really easily all I got is a
little bag of corn flour here some
refried beans and you get some either
mozzarella cheese or white Mexican queso
cheese
just going to add a little water
anyone in your house has celiacs disease
this is gluten free too so nice little
food you can enjoy you want to add just
enough water where it starts to feel
like Play-Doh but it doesn't stick to
your hands
filling is so simple it's just one part
beans to one part cheese if you want you
can also add jalapenos or hot sauce but
it's easy
I am a
just kind of make a little pocket and
then grab all the excess
and then just squish this thing into a
disc I could just feel all the Latina
grandmas out there cringing at my lack
of skills
try to make them a little flat they
they'll cook evenly if they're flat as
opposed to domed
hey it looks like Jill's family arrived
Joel has a son about Jacob's age so we
thought we'd do a little survival play
date we gotta get a handshake from you
what's your name sir Talon yeah is that
Talon like a bird Cowan Eagle challenge
there we go got some little papoosas
there do you want to grab one of those
kind of hot sure yeah split those with
your boy and I'll split this one with
Jake oh man look at that cheese is just
melting out yeah give it a go
that's really simple for three
ingredients right the corn flour is
great in El Salvador they eat pupusas
with pickled cabbage I really wish I had
some right now but this ain't bad
oh what you got there you got some uh
veggies and tofu there just a bunch of
veggies and some tofu in fact that
squash there is from our garden oh nice
oh yeah yeah that Ginger that sounds
good well that was a great little lunch
so good Jacob even though it's still
long enough to eat some stuff
all right we finished up lunch now we're
gonna go check those traps I got a
feeling we got some squirrel on the menu
oh my goodness definitely going
perfect good good Humane look at that
daddy's head is
strong all right
all right should we go find the other
trap yeah let's go find it
all right oh
here's the camera flashback
foreign
[Music]
yeah two hours three traps sprung that's
a lot of squirrels you want to go and
eat your chipmunk
and can we name them Widow little you
should call him Alvin or Flat Stanley
I'm right
I'm gonna do is have you put your
fingers under it
don't worry yeah
the kidneys all right we're gonna we're
gonna save the Chipmunk guts for a
crawfish trap we're gonna put out
tonight
a little bit of chipmunk meat this is
gonna be interesting may not look like a
lot of meat but that'll feed 20 picky
eaters
Joe's put together a little cooking
stand here
what happens is when you put this crust
Beam on it just gets wedged in place
held in place and then what we can do is
tie a rope over here with the toggle
that fits in the pot lid you get a place
of honor Perfect all right what do you
what are you what are you thinking what
do you want to do I'd like to do this
friction fire I'd like to learn more
about making fire with friction methods
it makes a lot of sense because now
we've got food we've got to cook it I've
got stuff to do Bow drill and I've just
have to do hand drill let's do a hand
drill um you can't just go find any old
straight piece of stick and start a fire
so ideally
it should have a hollow or like a pithy
soft Center should be really uh
lightweight and dried out there's a
various types of reeds and stalks that
work really well some of them would be
like Mullen and seep Willow and dog Bane
and Sycamore there's the fire board has
to be very very soft yeah bow drill you
have a lot more forgiveness a lot more
room for error but not with this because
here's the thing is you have a few
attempts before your hands are just
destroyed you want to try and get your
full hands in there and once you feel
like it's warmed up as when you can
start applying the downward pressure you
kind of smell the smoke before you see
it
just gotta squeeze that spindle a little
more
okay I got it
no I just went out yet we just went out
all right all right take two
I'll try and squeeze that
you kids aren't getting dirty are you
Jacob
what did you do that boy takes a dust
bath like a gerbil I really get that
down to pressure
squeeze the spindles
just a little bit longer yeah
I felt like I was so close but my arms
are just giving out I am so tired so
we're gonna try a different way we're
gonna try the bow method with the bow
drill method you don't need as long of a
spindle so we're gonna cut one from this
piece of Alder here and luckily it's
really really dry and it's been dry for
a while here in Oregon so that makes
life a lot easier
I want to kind of hear it snapping that
might be trying to get the bow a little
lower to the ground
uh we might have bottomed out too oh
that is smoking like a chimney
oh yeah
well we're getting a lot of smoke but no
Embers and you can see here on the tip
it looks all yellowish that often is a
sign that there's too much resin in the
wood and the resin makes a lot of smoke
but doesn't make good Embers so we're
gonna try some different wood
foreign
it's not looking very good to me you see
the yellow right there we know something
has too much resin first we thought it
was a spindle but now we're thinking
maybe it's the fire board so we're gonna
switch up the fire board with that Alder
and see what happens
yeah you don't open too hard you don't
want something too hard beautiful just
like this
oh
son of a gun just don't get too erratic
but yeah that was that
oh man that looks so good at the end
there
I gotta give this a break or I'm not
gonna be able to lift my arms scratch my
nose you'll get it huh you'll get it
nothing like spending three hours trying
to create friction fire to make you
appreciate a lighter ah
oh we got some fresh uh elk meat from
one of the the rear legs oh nice we're
gonna get some elk stew
all right there's our chipmunk a little
bit of seasoning to it
the chocolate oh
[Music]
Just Clips in there
we'll get some bait inside here all
right got some chipmunk guts wow he's
all right we're just let that crawfish
trap sit overnight see what we got in
the morning
the sun's just starting to set look at
that crazy rainbow
oh how is that chipmunk looking
perfectly roasted love the liver
I'll pick the liver on the kidneys and
the heart over any of the the regular
flesh for sure well I wouldn't want to
take that from you you know you enjoy it
hey who wants to eat some Chipmunks I'm
gonna try the Chipmunk yeah you like
this it's like rabbit which one do you
want buns what do you think Jake you
like the Chipmunk
why don't you take that little one there
that's the kidney that's like the
all right we're we're trying chipmunk
kidneys here
that was an interesting ride
yeah not bad no take the leg all right
we've got Chipmunks legs you want more
nah that's actually not bad
they look like Duck a rabbit so I'm
gonna break off the rib cage
now eat this with the bones don't even
truth the bones are so soft that you can
chew them and swallow them okay
there we go chew it up it's really good
they're not bad
[Laughter]
I'll eat all the bones oh man broth is
looking beautiful yeah it is potatoes
doing in flavor infused oh that's real
stone ground oh yeah that ain't the real
stuff here
may I very oh look at that
that's the first time I've had elk I
think really I think so we're gonna have
elk meat
elk meat
no not else not not elf meat elk meat
that is a good looking stew the sweet
potatoes oh yeah they're great I don't
blame you there
take you are covered in flour and dirt
you like it yeah yeah it's good is it
so how did you how did you hear
trangle it
Jake did you like your elk stew
buddy are you tired you want to go to
bed all right let's get you into town
here we originally planned on making
some shelters but uh the friction fire
thing took a lot of time and so I'm
really glad we set up the tent this is
why you bring it back up
all right buddy why don't you hop in and
get inside your sleeping bag there yeah
you're you got to be sleepy it's it's
really late your time
okay buddy all right before I go to bed
I'm gonna make some bread dough because
I want to have fresh bread in the
morning so we're gonna mix it together
real quick it's super easy just get
yourself some bread flour or something
with a nice high gluten content
you know I was trying to spill as much
on the ground as you can sprinkle some
yeast in there really doesn't matter how
much take a little bit of sugar doesn't
really matter how much a little room
temperature water
all right we'll just let that sit till
morning
well guys me and Joe have had a good
time chatting by the fire but the jet
lag's killing me I need to go to bed I'm
gonna see you guys in the morning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
last night it's uh it's properly chilly
oh you see I get a fire started do you
like that
foreign
or you get a nice big roaring fire so
when the boys get out of their tent they
have something warm to stand next to but
we're also gonna need to cook breakfast
and for that I'm gonna need coals so I
want a whole bunch of very consistently
sized wood on a whole bunch of wood
about this big around
good morning
sleep okay I'm doing all right well I'm
a bit stuffy but that's okay you know
what's you know what secure is that
we're jumping that cold water over there
oh I you know it cleared up right now I
think
oh yeah
AJ Hey Jake why don't you come sit by
your fire with the friends
you throw on the big stuff first let it
burn a little bit then you throw on the
smaller stuff and then the smallest
stuff and then it all becomes Kohl's at
the same time but the general rule of
thumb is that for one inch of radius it
takes one hour to burn to coals so here
in about 45 minutes we should have a lot
of coals
well before we get breakfast started
we're gonna go check the Crawdad trot
luckily we are chipmunk killing experts
so we would survive anyways guys you
know what we need for breakfast
we need hot dog roasting sticks because
we've got breakfast Hot Dogs you guys
want to go find a hot dog stick yeah
yeah let's take a look at our dough and
see how it did overnight
check that out look at all the bubbles
in there that's exactly what you want to
see
it's all nice and puffy and bubbly you
know it got down into the low 40s upper
30s last night but it's still still
managed to ferment a little bit just
slows the process way down all right we
got our butter here
pop the lid on that
let's sit that by the fire that's what
we want yeah nice pile of coals
now I don't mean to brag but that's a
beautiful pile of coals right there
do you know what maybe I should share
one of these between you boys that
you're not bouncing off the walls
because that's quite a lot is here
there's no holes here there's no walls
here Daddy uh the logic's invaluable got
my little t-ball here so we're gonna put
some loose leaf herbal tea in there and
we got pineapple bacon breakfast
sausages we take survival very seriously
yeah tough Latvia in the woods right now
but that is a serious sausage stick
all right oh that's getting a little hot
[Music]
chocolate before it gets cold oh yeah
you guys still look at that we got some
melted butter
it's really gooey sticky and sugary I
hope you guys like that
oh look at that not too bad
yeah yeah no problem but uh
there we go nice piece
nice
honey honey with the sausage
oh just wrap it up eat that thing hot
dog on on steroids that's more of a bore
in a sleeping bag than a pig in a
blanket right yeah not too bad huh no
that's impressive yeah and it's so easy
I'm gonna do this
I'm trying to convince them
well we just finished breakfast and
cleaned up a little bit now I think we
try to do some more survival skills and
uh I'm gonna try some Flint napping and
I've never done that before if you don't
know what Flint knapping is when you
shape stones into arrowheads and knives
and spear points and things like that
foreign
Jacob's like obsidian that's for
Minecraft
now you can see that something piece is
being knocked out over here
chirpy Burpee Jacob
yeah so these are flakes that's a knife
that I was that I'm busy working on very
good grade of obsidian but
got a little flake see how that
and then just kind of work it down to
a thin flake that we can work with see
how it's taking off quite a bit
then you push down and in if you wanted
to remove some big flakes
nice that looks like that could be a
little Arrowhead that's it work with
that one I don't know that looks like a
nice thick this kind of already a pretty
good shape I think perfect
oh yeah like like you literally pressure
this is very manly you can feel my chest
hair growing in thicker
chest there
well there you go my first Flint
knapping project it's a little bit ugly
but I'm proud of that it's like a little
uh small spearhead or something okay do
you want to try Flint napping yeah
yeah
cool
oh see that it came off hey it's got a
little uh little blade there should we
put a handle on it yeah
yes it's delicious
all right there we go got some little
notches on it
Joel has some Pine pitch we're gonna
melt in the fire to make a glue
so Joel's ground up some charcoal here
he's mixing it in with the pine pitch in
act as a little bit of a binder
all right so we got that
it's great for like time around and
surprisingly we touch it quickly it
actually doesn't burn or anything
I think we got you a knife do you want
to see if we can cut something with it
do that
wait do you like your knife Jacob yes
is it a knife gun yeah a little knife
here we've got we're making all sorts of
primitive shifts
look at that we've got two little boys
with stone daggers who are having the
time of their lives
hey Jacob should we make a sheath for
your knife
[Music]
the knife goes in
the constantly talking about
[Music]
oh he's well there you go that's my
first time making cordage all right Jake
just put it on your neck and take a look
you show me your knife buddy show the
camera
oh my goodness is that so cool yeah you
have made a caveman knife
all right I want to rematch with that
spindleboard
that's a tag team of two yeah
oh you make that look easy
you basically got it all prepared for me
I just went down the spindle twice and
it was done all right we're gonna try
the bow method we're gonna look for new
wood for a spindle this is a dead Willow
of course it has to be dead we can't
have moisture this is uh perfectly round
and straight the exact diameter we want
when it has this like red Hue to it I've
always found that that is sort of an
indicator that it's it's dried the right
amount
yeah leave the bark on
um actually find that it makes uh makes
it a bit stronger foot closer to here
I think you got it
oh oh I think you got it
definitely got it see the smoke coming
out of the pile it does you got it man
that does power but you definitely got
it yeah you can see the smoke just still
going even though we stopped
there it is got a Denver okay take this
Amber
then
put it in there
there you go
well there we go guys that is the first
time I've ever successfully made an
ember with the bow drill method and
little piece of Alder and Willow we
found right here that was cool yeah
thanks a lot Joe oh yeah man good job
now my arm's gonna fall off
it was just
oh yeah
they stick that in there too that should
be heated up do you still boil it yeah I
just we're gonna boil it and I'll put a
set of timer on my phone for 11 minutes
you guys
you guys with dogs
done it's gonna be yeah you want a
cooked one or a raw one
so yeah and if you like spice yeah
oh guys this has been fun but we gotta
start packing it up
this takedown
listen guys me and Jacob had a wonderful
time and I learned a lot of new things
so if you're ever in the Northwest and
you want to do this too check out Joel
vanderloon's survival school I'll put a
link to his website in the video
description below as well as a link to
his YouTube channel as well he's got
some pretty cool Adventures both here
and in Tanzania up on his YouTube
channel so I'll link to that in the
video description thank you very much
for having us and thanks thanks for
hanging with us Alan yeah but yeah it
was awesome thank you so much thank you
yeah all right I'll see you Joel
was that fun Jake yeah
Jacob did you have fun it was a very
good time well listen if you guys had a
good time too make sure to click
subscribe to the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel because we put out new videos
every Saturday morning I'll see you next
Saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button and you'll
get notifications thanks for watching